Europe's politicians are looking for a
way out of the economic crisis and most
importantly they're increasingly doing
it together mebs and members of national
parliaments met for two days of talks
about making the economy work to close
the existing Democratic deficit in the
new economic governance framework we
need stronger involvement by both the
national parliaments and the European
Parliament there is a growing
recognition that austerity alone is not
the answer but that doesn't mean tearing
up the rulebook and that includes the
new government in Greece nor eglin do
have the veneer pretty visible through
the veneer Pacifica's the car the very
clearly noted what it a respective are
too legit a marble it are two League of
animal kills what nouveau who killed so
what please XP romantic even so the
emphasis is showing signs of shifting
from more cuts to greater investment in
growth not quite keynesianism but close
we are not advocating now and
traditional public spending but clearly
the more precise very precise kukil
approach that of the of the fiscal
policy of last year probit to be an
effective not only an effective respect
to growth and jobs but also an effective
respect to their goal to reduce the
depth the signs of growth are still
elusive that with everybody working
together there may be a spark of hope
but the crisis will end
you